yo
juro solemnemente que defenderé la
constitución
de un nuevo alcalde para los
neoyorquinos 'times square' los yo jurar
en plena celebración de año nuevo con el
objetivo de sacar a la ciudad de la
pandemia nueva york está aliando
actualmente con un número récord de
casos de kobe 19 impulsados por la
variante omicron que no podemos volver a
cerrar nuestra ciudad y no podemos
permitir que la ciudad se sumerja más en
la desesperación económica y voy a poner
en marcha un plan general y jenson
cuenta esta ciudad ha tenido más de 40
mil positivos diarios de kobe 19
últimamente adams asegura que mantendrá
un requisito de vacuna para empleadores
del sector privado una medida
implementada por su predecesor bill de
blasio además afirma que el enfoque
seguirá siendo reducir la desigualdad de
acceso a las pastillas antivirales
cuando estas píldoras estén disponibles
para la distribución masiva vamos a
asegurarnos de que se haga de manera
equitativa comer
al comienzo del cob y no hubo una
distribución justa de las pruebas ni una
distribución equitativa de las vacunas
no vamos a hacer eso con los antivirales
en salvar a ese hombre de 61 años es uno
de una limpiadora de casas y fue capitán
de policía de la ciudad de nueva york
antes de dedicarse a la política se ha
descrito a sí mismo como el futuro del
partido demócrata otros de sus desafíos
son el desempleo de nueva york que se
acerca al 10% y los delitos violentos
que actualmente son más altos que antes
de la pandemia de kobe 19